[موسيقى]
المترو يعمل بطريقه سلسه جدا هناك العديد
من الرحلات ويمكرون التنقل والوصول بسرعه
وبيئه اسعار اقل نعم هناك حافله تنقلنا هو
العديد من المرشدين الذين يقومون بارشادنا
لمختلف الخطوط ومع بطاقه هيا التنقل
المجاني
كلش ماشي مليحه وميترو كلش التنظيم ما شاء
الله وقطر مستعده باش لهذا الحدث العالمي
وان شاء الله يكون احسن مونديال في
التاريخ ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
المتر ضخم ولطيف كل شيء نظيف وسريع وسهل
التنقل به نسال عن كل الخدمه مثل الحاجه
للذهاب الى ملعب الماء واطلب معرفه مكان
الملعب واي خط يجب علي اخذه وهم يجيبونني
بكل ود لا يمكنني قول شيء اخر كل شيء
يعجبني
[موسيقى]
كل شيء رائع المترو رائع يعني كل شيء
تبارك الله التنظيم كان جدا جدا جدا
مبدعين فيه
ماشي بعيده على الدوحه انها تكون في هذه
الابداع وصلتلها الدرجه طبعا انا اول مره
نركب في المترو وجاني جدا سهل وكمسح فيه
قاع الناس اللي يجي وان شاء الله للدوحه
يكونوا مع التمدين المترو لانه السرعه
دياله يعني
نتمنى التوفيق لبلادي اسود
[تصفيق]
بصراحه المتر هنا جميل بينقلق لكل نقطه
تبغاها في الدوحه انا يعني بتمشى كل يوم
في الدوحه كل يوم بروح مكان بالمترو
بيوصلني اللي يكون نقطه في الدوحه وفي
خلال اقل من نص ساعه بكون من شمال الدوحه
ابي اكون في جنبها انا انا يعني لو اعرض
علي انه خذ سياره ولا نروح بالمترو ولا
راح اروح
بالمتر بالسياره من الشمال للج
نوب يعني مع
الزحمه فبصراحه زي ما انت شايفه المترو
كراسي ومكيف ومرتب ونظيف جدا هذا شيء
يسعدنا وشكرا لهم شكرا على القائمين على
هذا يعني متر الدوحه شيء جميل
اوكي تسلم
[موسيقى]